ahora muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 soy santiago ariztía y en esta
oportunidad nos acompaña el en ahora
bidegaín ella es hija del ex magistrado
auxiliar del consejo de estado carlos
horacio urán quien fuera asesinado por
las fuerzas armadas de colombia en un
hecho histórico que marcó por siempre al
país estamos hablando del asalto al
palacio de justicia y es autora del
libro mi vida y el palacio en el que
hace un recorrido a través de su vida
atravesada y por supuesto marcada por
una de las peores tragedias que ha
vivido colombia elena ahora me dejáis
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 es un placer
hola muchas gracias bueno en primer
lugar me gustaría pedirle a usted que le
cuenta en nuestra audiencia
especialmente nuestra agencia
internacional no que quizás no tiene en
su memoria ha marcado este episodio tan
trágico de la historia de colombia una
pregunta bueno que puede ser resultará
es difícil quizás larga para responder
pero necesitaría y quiero que usted
misma la responda no que pasó durante el
6 y 7 de noviembre de 1985 en bogotá
sí bueno los hechos ocurrieron el 6 y 7
de noviembre concretamente el 6 de
noviembre de 1985 cuando un comando de
la guerrilla del m-19 entró a tomarse
las instalaciones del palacio de
justicia con la idea de forzar a los
jueces de la república a realizar un
juicio político al presidente de la
época a belisario betancur porque
consideraban que habían que no había
cumplido con los acuerdos de paz
iniciados el año anterior entonces ellos
entraron y se tomaron el palacio y a las
muy pocos minutos llegó las fuerzas
armadas con tanques de guerra
con francotiradores al poco los pocos
minutos o a las pocas horas hubo fuego
dentro del palacio o sea sobre
reaccionaron con
pocas intenciones de rescatar a los
rehenes sino más bien de
atacar a la guerrilla pasando por encima
de la vida de todos estos civiles y en
los hechos terminaron con un saldo de
casi 100 personas muertas y 11
desaparecidas
elena bueno como tal como contadas en tu
libro no mi vida y el palacio que aquí
lo tengo en mis manos tenía tan solo 10
años cuando todo esto ocurría no como
recordad que lo vivía esa niña no en tu
libro parece en clave es esa en esas
vivencias las miradas y también los ojos
de tu madre no hay algo así que percibí
has
sí claro se fue fueron días de muchísima
angustia sin entender bien qué era lo
que pasaba porque es que ni los adultos
mucho menos un niño podía entender cómo
es que
el palacio de justicia la sede del poder
judicial era tomada por un grupo
guerrillero y después por el ejército
que entraba
para arrasar con todo o sea era algo
incomprensible de hecho tuvieron que
pasar muchos años para que pudiéramos
entender ese ese ese sinsentido y en el
libro pues relató cómo fueron esas horas
desde que mi mamá nos va a buscar a la
escuela qué pasaba en mi casa la
cantidad de preguntas la gente llamando
el teléfono sonando sin parar y después
buscando a mi papá por todos lados en la
morgue en las en los centros de salud
con los militares y no aparecía y no
aparecía y bueno
así que viví esos hechos a través de tu
relato y precisamente no como decíamos
los hechos sobre los que estamos
hablando están rodeados de muchísimos
interrogantes hay versiones que dicen
que los integrantes de la guerrilla
habían ejecutado los rehenes pero el más
fuerte consenso es que las muertes
fueron causadas por las propias fuerzas
armadas vos en tu libro hace referencia
a lo de la guerrilla del m-19 que
combinaba como decíamos anteriormente el
incumplimiento de un acuerdo de paz con
el gobierno también se habla de una
reacción sumamente desproporcionada por
parte del gobierno no 15 mil miembros de
las fuerzas armadas desplegadas para
combatir a unos 35 integrantes de esta
guerrilla hubo tanques ingresando al
palacio lanzamiento de bombas
helicópteros en la zona que hay detrás
para vos elena de todo esto
sí bueno la versión oficial que siempre
se manejó fue que la guerrilla era la
responsable y la única responsable y que
los magistrados habían muerto en manos
de estos guerrilleros o habían sido
calcinados y después de muchos años se
pudo comprobar por incluso por
investigaciones judiciales que por
ejemplo en el caso de mi papá no había
sido la guerrilla sino que mi papá logró
salir del palacio de justicia
después lo cayó en manos de los
militares los torturaron y la bala que
lo último era una bala de un arma que
solo tenía los altos
jefes militares entonces siempre ha
estado este relato oficial intentando
suprimir y evadir cualquier otra otra
versión y así se ha perpetuado la
impunidad
y bueno ahora yo intento con este con
este libro monta mostrar cómo lo vivimos
nosotros qué pasó a los 22 años después
cuando la justicia misma colombiana
esclarece los carlos los hechos y bueno
sin embargo se mantiene la impunidad del
caso porque al poco tiempo de que las
fiscales esclareciera esto intentará
llamar a los generales a ella la retiran
del caso y desde entonces no vamos a ver
nada más ahora llega otro factor que
rodea no a los hechos y que los rodea de
más polémicas por supuesto es que los
magistrados habían emitido condenas y
llevaban adelante investigaciones no
contra oficiales de las fuerzas
militares de hecho tu propio padre
pertenecía a una sección en la que se
habían proferido sentencias contra
integrantes del ejército del conocía
bien de cerca a los lazos entre el poder
militar y el gobierno o sea que los
magistrados se enfrentaban por un lado a
la guerrilla pero también a las fuerzas
armadas no usted qué lectura hace de
esto
sí bueno había por un lado estaba en ese
momento la corte suprema de justicia los
magistrados estaban llevando a cabo
casos por extradición de
narcotraficantes y por eso habían
recibido muchas amenazas de los capos de
la mafia y por otro lado en el consejo
de estado la sección tercera donde
trabajaba concretamente mi papá
estaban muchos procesos abiertos de
investigación por violación de derechos
humanos del ejército
y precisamente meses atrás antes de la
toma del palacio de justicia se había
condenado de manera histórica al
ejército por un caso de tortura a una
médica junto con su niñita de cinco años
algo que tenía muy molesto a los a los
militares entonces los magistrados
recibían no solamente amenazas de parte
de los de los narcotraficantes sino
también recibían amenazas de parte de
allegados a las fuerzas armadas pero esa
segunda parte sobre esas amenazas los
medios de comunicación masivo nunca le
contaron al país sólo se ha hablado de
de una de las partes de la historia
ahora una experiencia muy interesante
que contadas en el libro de cuando
conoces a rené el hermano de una de las
personas desaparecidas y que se había
unido a la guerrilla del m-19 según él
porque no toleraba a ver el dolor de sus
padres no por la pérdida de su hija y
decís en el libro que cuando él te
cuenta esto lo entendiste y lo admira se
nos contaría más en detalle cómo fue eso
que sentiste
o sea cuando yo cuento eso me refiero a
que sentía admiración de alguien de
intentar restablecer la dignidad robada
no en que él haya entrado a la guerrilla
porque igual que como lo veía mi papá
para mí las armas nunca van a llevar a
lograr la paz ni mucho menos
si no me refería con la parte que hablo
que lo admiraba porque él ha hecho un
esfuerzo ha dedicado toda su vida
a buscar la verdad sobre lo que sucedió
con su hermana y fue tanta la
humillación que recibió sus dos papás y
después el que no lo aguanto más y bueno
eso tendría que explicarlo más él pero
decidió unirse a la guerrilla
como digo yo la de las armas ni de un
lado ni del otro a mí no me parece que
sirva para nada más que para al final
tener más dolor y más sufrimiento pero
me refería más a buscar es restablecer
su dignidad
frente al atropello una y otra vez una y
otra vez de parte de del estado que no
que no ha respondido desde hace 35 años
y sigue valiendo y sigue mintiendo y
bueno todavía no se ha esclarecido los
los hechos ahora vinculado a esta
pregunta no esto que me contabas de rené
no y como me decías que si bien no lo
justificaba por supuesto si había como
un entendimiento una es de cierta manera
una comprensión no hay también en
contraste la respuesta a la pregunta que
plantea en su libro cuando te decís si
se puede esperar que la violencia de
quienes sufren violencia puede pelear
mejor dicho violencia por parte de
quienes sufren violencia desde el estado
si se puede esperar violencia de quienes
sufren digamos que es muy difícil
exigirle a alguien que siempre ha
recibido desprecio rechazo y atropello
que mantenga una compostura que los que
tienen que dar ejemplo no lo hacen
entonces
yo para mí es una reacción humana que
algunas personas decidan tomar ese
camino no quiere decir que sería lo que
yo haría porque como repito para mí al
final terminan más dolor pero puedo
entender el punto de partida porque
alguien decide tomar ese camino entonces
hay que pensar cuando hablamos de los
guerrilleros tenemos que pensar cuáles
son las razones que llevan a estas
personas a tomar ese camino qué es lo
que pasa para que una persona decida
irse por ese camino porque sin duda es
un camino lleno de dificultades y de
riesgos y
y no sé más bien la pregunta es por qué
lo hacen que hay para que llega una
persona a una situación de ilegalidad
como esas él era una amiga en muchísimas
gracias por estos minutos en france 24
a ustedes por la entrevista muchas
gracias a usted en esta audiencia como
siempre los invitamos a continuar
informándose en el resto de nuestra
programación y en france24 punto com
[Música]
y